[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka guten abend
der konflikt zwischen europa und belarus
kind gefährlich zu eskalieren polen
spricht nunmehr offen davon dass seine
grenze angegriffen wird und damit eine
der außengrenzen der eu man muss es wohl
in aller schärfe so sagen belarus
missbraucht die not von menschen und
setzt migranten als waffen eingerichtet
gegen europa mit welchem ziel
rache für die von der eu verhängten
sanktionen gegen belarus sind wir nur
eine seite der medaille
es geht um mehr europa unter druck zu
setzen zu destabilisieren wie kann und
sollte sich die eu dagegen wehren dazu
gleich ein gespräch doch zunächst
berichtet christian sehen wie sich die
lage im grenzgebiet zwischen polen und
belarus zuspitzt
gestrandet im nirgendwo für diese
kurdische familie endet die flucht erst
mal hier irgendwo im grenzgebiet
zwischen belarus und polen der machen
wir kommen aus dem irak wir sind auf dem
weg nach polen und haben eine harte zeit
hinter uns
sie lassen uns nicht von anderen
migranten geht es ähnlich sie sitzen
fest an der grenze zu europa dort haben
tausende die nacht bei minusgraden
verbracht am morgen kam polens
ministerpräsident morawietz und machte
den polnischen soldaten klar dass es
hier um mehr gehe als um den schutz der
landesgrenze
die grenze im osten die polnische grenze
ist auch die eu grenze gestern habe ich
mit der präsidentin der eu kommission
mit ministerpräsidenten verschiedener
staaten gesprochen jeder schickt euch
hochachtung und so funktioniert der
flüchtlings transfer von machthaber
lukaschenko durch belarus per direktflug
kommen die menschen aus damaskus
istanbul oder dubai nach - ein
einkaufszentrum als schleuser drehkreuz
immer wieder sieht man hier flüchtlinge
mit ihrem gepäck weiße transporter
bringen sie weg von hier offenbar
richtung grenze lukaschenko will damit
vor allem erreichen dass die
wirtschaftssanktionen gegen belarus
gelockert werden die eu hatte sie nach
den umstrittenen präsidentschaftswahlen
im letzten jahr und dem brutalen
vorgehen gegen opposition und medien in
belarus verhängt
warum wir davon ausgehen dass die
sanktionen greifen weil das lukaschenko
regime sich wie ein gangster regime
benimmt weil es ihnen weh tut und sie
nicht wissen was sie machen sollen also
versuchen sie die eu mit angriffen zu
untergraben
lukaschenko geht noch weiter in einem
interview mit einem russischen militär
journalisten droht er mit einer atomaren
eskalation des konflikts durch russland
wenn wir gott bewahre einen fehler
machen oder einen falschen schritt tun
dann wird das sofort russland auf den
plan rufen und russland ist eine
nukleare supermacht ich bin nicht
verrückt ich kann mir nur zu gut
vorstellen was sich daraus entwickeln
kann
im russischen staatsfernsehen laufen die
bilder von der grenze rauf und runter
der kreml schaut genüsslich zu europa im
chaos zu zeigen und gibt den westlichen
ländern die schuld für die eskalation
sie bemühen sich seit vielen jahren dem
nahen osten und nordafrika ein besseres
leben nach westlichem
eine demokratie in der form wie sie der
westen interpretiert und aggressiv
versucht sie auf der ganzen welt
durchzusetzen und als das auf einen
gewissen widerstand stieß gab es
militärische abenteuer
[Musik]
russland könnte im grenzkonflikt
einfluss nehmen auf diktator lukaschenko
doch wladimir putin hat daran kein
interesse im gegenteil
wenn wir über die krise an der grenze
sprechen können wir sagen dass sie unter
dem deckmantel russland stattfindet
russland deckt ist diplomatisch
politisch informativ und möglicherweise
militärisch und das passt zu lukaschenko
und russland denn je schlechter die
beziehungen von lukaschenko zum westen
desto besser für moskau
völlige flüchteten aus syrien dem irak
oder yemen endet die organisierte flucht
erst mal im eiskalten niemandsland unter
teils unmenschlichen bedingungen gelockt
hat sie alexander lukaschenko in die
sackgasse belarus
ja was geschieht da was steckt
pathetisch dahinter darüber wollen sie
mit einem ausgewiesenen
sicherheitsexperten sprechen mit carlo
masala professor für internationale
politik an der universität der
bundeswehr in münchen guten abend herr
professor seiner
schönen guten abend fußball murat was
für absichten was für eine strategie
verfolgt bela rußler ihrer einschätzung
nach
also belarus verfolgt eine strategie die
ich hybride oder nichtlineare
kriegsführung nennen würde zielt auf
sozusagen die idee stabilisierung
europäischer gesellschaften durch
migration sie zielt auf die entlassung
einer möglichen moralischen
doppelbödigkeit der europäischen union
und letzten endes will lukas schinko die
sanktionen die die eu gegen ihn
verhängen hat lockern und benutzt damit
menschen als ein nicht militärisch
erpressungspotenzial in einem
kriegsähnlichen szenario was meinen sie
mit entlarvung
europäischer behauptungen oder heuchelei
ja wie auch immer
es ist so natürlich dass die europäische
union als eine werte von sich behaupten
werte basierten gemeinschaft in denen
menschenrechte ein hohes gut sind jetzt
im prinzip mit der situation
konfrontiert ist dass die polen push
back betreiben dass die polen in der in
dieser grenzregion eigentlich alle
konventionen also die
kinderrechtskonvention die europäische
menschenrechtskonvention
verletzen und das kann man natürlich
propagandistisch wunderbar ausschlachten
wenn man in minsk oder in moskau setzt
wie sollte die eu ihrer ansicht nach
darauf reagieren
ich glaube es braucht eine gemischte
strategie also zum einen und das würde
ich mit resilienz bezeichnen wir dürfen
uns nicht erpressen lassen von
weißrussland das heißt lukas schenkel
nachzugeben sanktionen zu lockern oder
wie es sich heute andeutet ihm geld zu
geben damit er die flüchtlinge nicht
mehr zur grenze schickt ist wäre ein
kolossaler fehler das wäre sozusagen
einen sieg von belarus das wäre ein sieg
moskaus
meines erachtens müssen wir lukaschenko
zeigen dass wir uns vornehmlich
erpressen lassen und das ist eine
strategie die mehrere aspekte umfasst
also zum einen wir müssen die menschen
die dort in diesem grenzgebiet sind in
einem europäischen verfahren auf
europäische länder die bereit sind dies
zu tun verteilen wir reden hier von 3
bis 5000 menschen das ist keine grosse
masse wir müssen sofort sanktionen gegen
belarus verschärfen und meines erachtens
wäre die grösste sanktionen die wir
machen könnten wähle russ vom
internationalen zahlungsverkehr
abzuschneiden das würde diese wirtschaft
kollabieren lassen drittens wir müssen
den druck auf die airlines die die
flüchtlinge über moskau nach minz
bringen erhöhen und gegebenenfalls wenn
man nachweisen kann dass diese airlines
das diesen bewusst ist woran sie
beteiligt sind diese sanktionieren für
den europäischen flugverkehr und dann
letzten endes müssen die sanktionen
gegen diejenigen verschärft werden die
im prinzip hinter dieser strategie
stehen oder sie gar decken das ist
moskau der schlüssel für die belarus
situation liegt in moskau aber ein teil
dieser strategie wäre zu sagen dass
anstatt dass man jetzt an der grenze auf
diese hybride kriegsführung die er heißt
mit nicht traditionellem militärischen
mitteln sondern in dem fall flüchtling
hals waffen darauf nicht ebenfalls
militärisch zu reagieren sondern zu
sagen wir nehmen die jetzt ganz ruhig
auf das funktioniert aber ja in europa
bisher überhaupt nicht also die polen
werden das vermutlich nicht mitmachen
die wollen sich ja noch nicht mal von
den eu grenzschützern frontex helfen
lassen
ja das ist in der tat eine große aufgabe
die polen davon zu überzeugen gegen
diese harte lösung von dieser harten
lösungen abstand zu nehmen weil diese
harte lösung wird schmutziger und
dreckige bilder produzieren und es ist
ja nicht so dass das eine
flüchtlingsbewegung ist die sozusagen
als normale flüchtlinge kommt das ist
eine orchestrierte lukaschenko wird es
nicht davon abhalten noch weiter
flüchtlinge an die grenze zu schicken
und letzten endes werden polen nicht in
der lage sein gegen diese massen von
menschen die einfach sozusagen durch
dieses grenzgebiet wollen
diese zurückzuhalten ohne auf sie zu
schießen das wäre der schlimmste fall
der in europa passieren kann das muss
dem polen auch klar sein dass die
gesamte europäische idee da auch die
serviert wird wir werden sie nicht alle
staaten haben die die in europa
aufnehmen aber es wird eine reihe von
staaten geben und da ist sich um eine
begrenzte anzahl von flüchtlingen
handelt die dazu bereit sein werden und
die müssen wir sozusagen in europa
aufnehmen noch eine kurze fragen
sicherheitsexperten die polen ist auch
nato-mitglied wenn polen davon spricht
dass seine grenze angegriffen wird kann
man da auch richtung bündnisfall nato
denken
es gibt eine relativ unglückliche
äußerungen des nato-generalsekretärs
jens stoltenberg der sagt wir werden mit
allen mitteln den polen helfen das
konnte man militärisch interpretieren
das ist kein klassischer bündnisfall mit
dem mann auf den man militärisch
reagieren kann was die nato aber machen
kann die nato hat so genannte teams die
staaten dabei helfen des
informationskampagnen oder hybride
kampagnen
denen besser zu begegnen und das ist
eine maßnahme die nato ergreifen könnte
diese teams mit der zustimmung polens
nach polen zu schicken um den polen
dabei zu helfen hier mit einigen sachen
in dieser hybriden kriegsführung
zurechtzukommen militärische einsätze
halte ich für ausgeschlossen und auch
nicht wünschenswert dass wird die nato
mich machen einmal sei dann danken für
die analysen und einschätzungen
ich danke ihnen
es ist ja wir haben wir aufgezeichnet
und nachher im heute schon update gibt
es dazu noch ein gespräch mit dem
migrationsforscher gerald knaus
als den deutschen tag schlechthin
bezeichnete bundespräsident steinmeier
heute den neunter november ein
geschichtsträchtiger zwiespältiger tack
die ausrufung der republik 1918 fiel auf
einen neunten november die
nationalsozialisten welten das datum
dann für ihre pogromnacht 1938
und dann wieder ein neunter november der
mauerfall
aller drei historische einschnitte
gleichzeitig zu bedenken ist nicht ganz
leicht das war auch bei der
veranstaltung heute in schloss bellevue
zu spüren fischer berichtet
hier nimmt eine frau platz die gerade
geburtstag hatte die den neunten
november heute zum hundertsten mal
erlebt margot friedländer am morgen des
10 november 1938 will sie wie immer in
berlin so kleinschneider rey gehen in
die sie eine lehre absolviert niemand
wird hier im schloss bellevue heute zeit
so eindrücklich nach bezeugen wie margot
friedländer der morgen nach der
reichspogromnacht 38 gefüllte das wirft
anders war sonst meistens ist die luft
im november frisch und 3 ein komischer
stickiger und schwerer bruch weiter luft
ich hörte knirschen und er meint
ich war oft las getreten das glas der
jüdischen geschäfte die es nicht gab
wir wussten
das ist
der anfang von viel schlimmeren was noch
kommen wird
diese 19 novembertage sie haben viele
gesichter sie erzählen viele geschichten
diese novembertage wir hängen kaum
zusammen aber der dunkle von 1938 und
der helle von 1918 schon die ausrufung
der republik daran erinnert heute die
jüngste bundestagsabgeordnete
23 jahre alt und überzeugt dass die
jungen im parlament antworten haben
werden demokratie zu verteidigen heißt
heute auch unseren parlamentarismus
abzustauben
jetzt müssen wir gemeinsam neues
vertrauen wecken mit blumen wird unweit
von schloss bellevue derer gedacht die
am todesstreifen in berlin zu tode kamen
über das glück und die strahlkraft vom 9
november 1989 spricht einer im schloss
diktator ist überwindbar
dies ist das hoffnungszeichen aus
deutschland nach pedros china oder kuba
der neunter november dieser deutsche tag
ist ein widersprüchlicher aber eben ein
besonders wertvoller tag ich wünsche mir
dass wir ihn als solchen begehen dass
wir näher an uns heranlassen
als tag zum nachdenken über unser land
zum nachdenken das hat die veranstaltung
gezeigt aber braucht es menschen die die
kraft haben zeugnis abzulegen über die
hellen und die dunklen tage die sie
erlebt die sie überlebt haben
und jetzt dem wechsel und die
nachrichten
seit heute gilt der neue bußgeldkatalog
wer gegen die verkehrsregeln verstößt
muss mit höheren strafen rechnen
ziel sei es unter anderem die sicherheit
von fußgängern und radfahrern zu erhöhen
wer innerorts bis zu 20 kilometer pro
stunde zu schnell fährt zahlt statt
bislang 35 jetzt 70 euro bußgeld
außerdem kostet unerlaubtes parken auf
geh und radwegen oder in zweiter reihe
statt bisher 25 bis zu 110 euro
unberechtigtes parken auf plätzen für
elektro- oder carsharing autos 55 euro
wenn autofahrer keine rettungsgasse
bilden oder diese blockieren 200 bis 320
euro und ein monat fahrverbot
in tschechien ist oppositionsführer
petri fiala von präsident seemann mit
der regierungsbildung beauftragt worden
bereits gestern hatte fiat mit vier
weiteren parteien einen
koalitionsvertrag unterschrieben die
künftige liberal konservative koalition
verfügt über eine deutliche mehrheit im
abgeordnetenhaus und könnte die
bisherige regierung von amtsinhaber
barbisch ablösen
angesichts der sich ausbreitenden corona
infektionen in frankreich hat präsident
makro die situation als beunruhigend
bezeichnet die situation auf den
intensivstationen sei alarmierend sagte
makau am abend in einer fernsehansprache
er war für auffrischungsimpfungen auch
für menschen ab dem 50 lebensjahr
personen über 65 gelten ab mitte
dezember nur noch dann als geimpft wenn
sie eine so genannte booster impfung
nachweisen können
vor dem fußball länderspiel am
donnerstag gegen liechtenstein ist
abwehrspieler niklas süle wohl doppelt
geimpft positiv auf das corona virus
getestet worden schüle und vier weitere
nationalspieler mit denen er kontakt
hatte haben das dfb quartier in
wolfsburg verlassen nachdem das
vormittagstraining abgesagt wurde setzte
flick am abend doch noch eine einheit an
volland sowie die wolfsburger barcoo und
arnold ersetzen die abgereisten spieler
durch den wirbel um den positiv
getesteten süle wird das team erneut von
der pandemie eingeholt das muss man
jetzt so akzeptieren und auch damit
umgehen das machen wir auch in genua
weiterhin verantwortungsvoll mit um auf
anweisung des gesundheitsamtes mussten
auch gabri musealer adeyemi und kimmig
vom team isoliert werden weil sie als
kontaktperson 1 eingestuft wurden und
sich nun alle in quarantäne befinden die
länge der quarantäne das kann ich ihnen
letztlich nicht beantworten das ist in
der hand des lokalen gesundheitsamtes
das hängt auch davon ab ob beschwerden
auftreten das hängt davon ab wie
eventuelle folge tests ausfallen die
vorbereitung auf das spiel erheblich
gestört doch die begegnung am donnerstag
soll laut dfb nicht in gefahr sein
dass es auch die nationalmannschaft
trifft ist nicht verwunderlich delta
rauscht er quasi quer durchs land die
zahl der gemeldeten neuinfektionen hat
sich im vergleich zur vorwoche praktisch
verdoppelt auf 21800
32 aktuell liegt die sieben tage
incidents bei
213,7
das ist aber ja nur der bundesweite
durchschnittswert für die gesamte
bevölkerung unter den ungeimpften ist
die inzidenz sehr viel höher denn auch
wenn es inzwischen viele impft
durchbrüche gibt so ist nach wie vor die
ansteckungsfähigkeit für geimpfte
geringer ganz abgesehen vom risiko eines
schweren krankheitsverlaufs vor dem die
impfung ja in erster linie schützen soll
außerdem gibt es große regionale
unterschiede in sachsen thüringen und
bayern sind die instanzen am höchsten in
bayern liegen einige landkreise schon
bei werten von über 800 die kliniken
laufen voll
ministerpräsident müller prüft ob er den
katastrophenfall ausrufen muss aus
münchen stefan leifert
es ist eine neue erfahrung für markus
söder ein land anzuführen dass so
schlecht dasteht wie kaum ein anderes
beim impfen den ec gentzen in den
krankenhäusern bayern muss zurückkehren
zu strengen verschärfungen sodass
entschlossenheit im ton verdeckt
ratlosigkeit in der sache
gesundheitsministerium und polizei
zusammen mit den
kreisverwaltungsbehörden werden eine
massive erhöhung der kontrolldichte
machen die polizei wird ab jetzt direkte
geldstrafen aussprechen bei verstößen
und bei wiederholten fragen ob jetzt in
der gastronomie bei einrichtungen oder
ähnlichen räumen dann auch
vorübergehende schließungen anordnen es
sind landkreise wie traunstein die
bayerns politik so ratlos machen die
inzidenz steuert auf 1000 zu die
krankenhäuser voll die impfquote weit
unter dem bundesschnitt wir haben uns
über den ganzen sommer den mund fusselig
geredet haben sie dem erklärt was
passieren wird es ist genau so gekommen
ist die politik und die experten gesagt
haben und jetzt möchte plötzlich jeder
sofort zur impfung aber bin schon froh
wenn sie jetzt in die richtung geht
noch ist der impfschutz mehr hoffnung
als realität die mobilen impf teams wie
hier in der oberpfalz verabreichen vor
allem booster und wenig erstimpfungen
bayern will nun alle impfzentren wieder
hochfahren doch die impfbereitschaft
scheint erschöpft und zu stoßen die
intensivstationen wieder an ihre
belastungsgrenze es ist bayerns großes
corona tisch erfüllt mit einem
unterschied es sind überwiegend
ungeimpfte die hier liegen der münchen
klinik sind 21 von 26 intensivpatienten
ungeimpft das personal am ende seiner
kräfte die ausgangslage ist nicht ganz
andere jetzt wir haben personal des
erschöpft ist das gut los ist zum teil
ist müde ist frustriert ist dann haben
wir incidents die heute höher sind und
wir haben ein ganz normales notfall
geschäfte haben kein lockdown jetzt was
auch gut ist ich möchte auch keinen blog
da wir haben aber das muss man sehen und
deswegen weiß ich dass die situation für
uns in diesem winter wahrscheinlich
schwieriger werde für erklärungsversuche
wieso es gerade in bayern so weit kommen
konnte haben sie hier keine zeit andreas
benz ag bereitet seine firma auf die
nächste runde der verschärfungen vor 3g
am arbeitsplatz das heißt im nachweise
oder testergebnisse kontrollieren was er
eigentlich gar nicht darf wir müssen
sagen nein müssen uns im prinzip auch
speichern und dürfen uns nicht und das
ist schon eine deutliche lücke die
wieder von der wirtschaft ausgelassen
wird in bayern gilt seit heute zweig für
großveranstaltungen das fußballstadion
wird zum ort für geimpfte ebenso
konzerthäuser und theater in restaurants
gilt noch 3g die politik ist am ende
ihrer ideen beschwört flehentlich weiter
das impfen es geht um timing die noch
schwanken und ich möchte so viel wie
möglich noch bewegen können sich impfen
zu lassen wir hoffen sie dass zweig
einschub ist aber wir glauben einfach
jetzt ist vorlaufende intensivstationen
muss augenscheinlich will ich einmal
jedem bewusst machen was man sich und
andere gefährdet
die langsame rückkehr zur leichtigkeit
ist ausgebremst ob und für wen hier bald
weihnachtskonzerte stattfinden ist
wieder offener denn je der einzelhandel
erwartet laut dem münchner ifo-institut
weiter lieferprobleme das ist das
ergebnis einer ifo-umfrage worauf müssen
sich die verbraucher da einstellen bei
der real und was sie die erwartungen wie
lange es noch lieferprobleme gibt
einzelhändler erwarten dass sich die
verzögerung bis weit in den sommer
nächstes jahr hinziehen das hat
natürlich auch folgen wartezeiten sind
lang und manche produkte erst mal gar
nicht verfügbar
das ifo institut warnt also vor
eingeschränkte auswahl zu weihnachten
und sogar noch lange danach besonders
betroffen von den lieferengpässen ist
die fahrradbranche da fehlt es offenbar
an allen ecken und enden von schaltungen
lenkern laufrädern bis zu speziellen
teilen für e bikes und die probleme
dürften noch eine weile andauern mit 18
monaten lieferverzögerungen rechnen die
fahrradhändler und sind somit so
pessimistisch wie keine andere branche
bei den möbelhändlern sind es 13 monate
die spielzeug händler gehen von rund elf
monaten aus und die baumärkte von über
10 die gründe sind vielfältig viele
firmen haben in der korona krise ihre
produktion heruntergefahren und wurden
dann vom boom überrascht außerdem rächt
sich dass viele unternehmen aus
kostengründen kleine lager haben und bei
ihrer produktion auf passgenaue
teilelieferungen setzen und wenn es da
an einer stelle hakt kommt die ganze
produktion ins stocken kosten die die
unternehmen zum teil auf die kunden
abwälzen
ein großteil der vom ifo institut
befragten unternehmen kündigen also auch
höhere preise an spätestens im
weihnachtsgeschäft dürfte sich das
bemerkbar machen valerie haller vielen
dank
am abend ist in berlin der preis
gemeinsam gegen das verbrechen der zdf
sendung aktenzeichen xy ungelöst
verliehen worden
bundesinnenminister seehofer überreichte
die mit jeweils 10.000 euro dotierte
auszeichnungen insgesamt drei
preisträger
sie hätten zivilcourage bewiesen und
sich mutig für andere eingesetzt die
jüngste preisträgerin war 16 als im
hessischen volkmarsen ein amokfahrer in
den karnevalsumzug raste sie hinderte
den täter an der weiterfahrt
nach fast 200 tagen auf der
internationalen raumstation sind vier
astronauten wieder sicher zurück auf der
erde sie landeten rund acht stunden nach
dem abdocken mit ihrer kapsel in der
nacht im meer vor der us-küste die
nachfolge besatzung soll frühestens am
donnerstag unserer zeit zur iss starten
mit anbaut bahnen der deutsche matthias
maurer
das war's im heute-journal gleich
gezerrte reportage reihe 37 grad weiter
heute mit dem titel täglich ein tier
leben für das sonderangebot
die in deutschland fleisch produziert
wird und um 0 uhr gibt's dann uns heute
mal update mit christina von ungern
sternberg ist morgen auf wiedersehen
oder sind
[Musik]
guten abend über nordeuropa ziehen
kräftige tiefsten weg richtige stieß
unsere hochdruckbrücke die er vom
atlantik bis zum schwarzen meer reicht
zieht etwas weiter nach osten aber am
spannendsten auf dieser wetterkarte ist
dieses tief über dem westlichen
mittelmeer
denn das dreht sich dort schon seit
tagen und wird das auch noch in den
nächsten tagen tun es bringt viel regen
mit viel wind und auch hohe wellen wir
könnten das sonntag in dieser region
durchaus zum teil mehr als 100 liter
regen pro quadratmeter erwartet ganz
anderes wetter bei uns nämlich einfach
nur ruhiges spätherbst wetter in der
nacht gibt's ein paar dichtere
wolkenfelder im nordwest sonst ist es
häufig klar dass bildet sich wieder
nebel unter den dichteren wolken im
nordwesten und an der ostsee bleibt die
nacht mild mit 10 bis 7 grad sonst aber
gehen die temperaturen auf plus 2 bis
minus 4 grad runter am boden wird also
überall frostig und dann kann es auch
mal glatt sein die höchsttemperaturen
morgen liegen meist um die 10 grad hält
sich der nebel sie werden kaum fünf grad
erreicht am alpenrand mit leichter föhn
unterstützung gibt's aber sogar 14 grad
auch morgen gibt's wieder dichtere
wolkenfelder nordwesten und dann kann es
zum beispiel hier in der schlei oder
auch auf sylt etwas regnen zwischen den
ostfriesischen inseln der lübecker bucht
sind die wolken eher dicht über
norddeutschland ziehen dann einige
schleierwolken hinweg da wird der himmel
nicht mehr so ganz klar blau sei in
süddeutschland muss ich erstmal nebel
auflösen das wird wahrscheinlich nicht
mehr ganz so gut klappen wie noch heute
und ganz ähnlich geht es in den nächsten
tagen auch weiter guten abend